rien ne vaut le plaisir de déguster un
thé au perle par une suffocante journée
d'été c'est la boisson nationale une
partie de l'identité taïwanaise
impossible d'y résister ces étudiants en
achète plusieurs fois par semaine
la recette est simple t aromatisée sucre
lait et petite boule de tapis au cas
ici on mélange encore le thé à bulle à
la main bienvenue chez John sweeton
reconnu comme l'inventeur de la boisson
en 1983
ce petit musée offre des ateliers sur le
thé et il plonge les visiteurs dans
l'histoire
en moins de 40 ans le thé aux perles a
connu un essor fulgurant même des
marchés comme l'Inde se tournent vers la
boisson la production mondiale de boules
de tapioca dépasse même les 300 tonnes
par jour
de people use of the
cosmoscope en Europe et en Amérique du
Nord le thé opel vient maintenant en
variété de toutes les couleurs et
saveurs ce qui effraie la fille de
l'inventeur de la boisson
qui voit surtout des produits
artificiels il n'y a pas que le breuvage
certains plats au friandises sont aussi
offerts certains sont assez particuliers
comme la pizza au thé aux perles par
exemple mais d'autres sont assez réussi
c'est la nouveauté qui était faire ta
Taïwan durant la saison estivale le
bubble tea hotpot la fondue avec
bouillon au thé aux perles un surprenant
et heureux mélange épicé salé et
légèrement sucré
des jeunes adultes sont régales près du
tiers des clients en ont fait l'essai
autre classique à Taïwan se desserre
qu'on appelle la glace pilée une des
variétés populaires et celles au thé aux
perles avec sirop d'érable de quoi
donner des idées au restaurateurs
canadien ici Philippe Leblanc
Radio-Canada Taipei